he is baseball hall-of-famer and my
longtime ESPN colleague Joe Morgan here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Joe
well it's your fault you haven't talked
to me that's a great Joe Morgan way to
start this thing I love it I love it
I'm glad you missed it but you know the
health care was a couple of years ago
and I am perfectly fine now essence
hobbling around looked at on a needed I
had a knee replacement it has caused me
some problems but tell us why I'm doing
great
so I'm glad to be talking to you as well
Joe how much how much baseball you you
taken in you watch my heart taking it
all in what do you got for me Joe yeah
yeah I actually worked for the Reds on
other side versus reds and I have been
for a long time and so I'm involved you
know with them on a daily basis so to
speak and then I watch baseball because
I love baseball so yeah I am for me it
was just about everything that's going
on what do you think about tuve Joe what
do you think that little phase the best
player in the game people won't give him
credit and I think it starts he's five
six or whatever I mean I don't know what
else you can do I mean he hits home runs
he drives in runs he still faces he
plays defense and I don't know what any
score runs I don't know if there's
anything else you gonna feel but I'm
really and you admire him just the way
he goes about his business unless facies
one three batting championship so I mean
all these other guys are real good but I
think he's the best and most consistent
what's the reason why you heard most
said you couldn't when you were playing
when they said Joe Morgan can't won't
what's the big reason you got they said
you can't play because you're too small
right that it wasn't any specific thing
because I always had speed and believe
it not when I was younger I had a really
strong arm because I was a shortstop and
I always could hit the ball farther than
the guys on our own hey you know but it
was still just too small I think that
was that was the thing it wasn't that
couldn't play you know I remember when I
was being scouted a lot of things would
say man you ain't great little Blair
you know little was always included and
one of the reasons I signed with the
Houston Astros
colt 45 at the time was because their
Scout never mentioned anything other
than that was a great player he's never
mentioned little so that stuck with me
it wouldn't matter because I had in my
own mind what I could do Joe Morgan
baseball hall-of-famer joining me here
in the Rich Eisen show a lot of
hand-wringing last year about pace of
play now it's about quality of play and
I got to tell you
Payson player was never really concerned
about because I was always gonna sit
there and watch a game no matter no
matter what and I understand about a
younger generation I am definitely more
concerned about quality of play I mean
the all-star game is kind of a perfect
example 48 percent of the game was
either a walk strikeout or a home run
and that seems to be the way things are
going right now are you concerned about
a job definitely concerned because you
know we were like to talk about you know
when I played and so forth when I played
it was different and today's game is
different I'm not going to say mine was
better this is worse it's just different
and you have to get accustomed to what's
going on and I've been doing that so to
speak it just bothers me all the
strikeouts you know the home runs
you know just the v long ball so people
are gonna start it over
come on runs you know the fact that
there's just not much action even though
they all-star game the greatest players
in the game are out there on the field I
never saw a great defensive plays you
know I never saw guys and run in space
because I never saw its body stealing
bases all I saw was guys standing there
swing hit homeruns and and you know okay
they connected ten times so I guess
that's the way to do it but there were
25 or so strikeouts if I remember
correct a lot of strikeouts so I mean
that's just the way the game is played
now attention strikeout walk or home run
things people are doing now and the
shifts are making it even worse guys you
know to try to hit for an average so you
know the game is different again you
know a lot of adjustments have to be
made as far as I'm concerned to make
this really really interested quads were
you ever stationed in short right field
I mean no you never did that no shift
like that yeah well I got in right short
right with the cubby with it so it's no
hard you know somebody you know that's
gonna hit it hard and they didn't run
that well but now I watch them they
shift on
guys that are not really slow runners or
not really guys that bang the ball you
know it's just a normal you know course
of its the defense that they played in
2018 you know they just move dad's
around
so what's the fix if you could wave if
you could make a change Joe what a big
it has to come from the players you know
first of all none of this you know you
know and I hear this about stopping this
shift and all that kind of stuff I don't
agree with that because that's like
telling the guy you can't throw Grich
eyes and a curveball because you can't
hit it you gotta throw him fastball so
he can hit it that's not right guys have
to make adjustments they have to go the
other way if they do that a few times
they're gonna stop the ship but guys
want to hit through the shift or over
the ship and they wanted it over it
cause you know the home runs are what
they're paying for now and so it has to
come from the players I don't think
legislate this game the way you know
like for it to be so I think it's gonna
be on the players if the players stay
that way better general matters and pay
the guys who do the right thing you know
I see guys hit 20 G's product run do
they make a lot of money and I'm always
like guys to make money all because you
know players I think we're shortchanged
years but now to make a lot of money and
that's great but I also want the quality
like you say the game the contention and
it can't continue with guys are gonna
try to keep hitting through to shift
Hall of Famer Joe Morgan here on the
Rich Eisen show Joey I'm sure you're
seeing the headlines about sports
gambling and how it's going to become
more prevalent in America and sports
leagues are now going to entertain the
idea of how to monetize it do you think
with that now being a new backdrop that
baseball should revisit the case of Pete
Rose for enshrinement in the whole thing
let me back up for a second I just
talked about you know the game and
gambling first of all years ago I was
asked as part of us you know I guess the
experiment to decide where the next you
know expansion team was going this
before Tampa Bay and everything and they
talked about Las Vegas
and I was against it because I felt like
if you get the players in Las Vegas you
just don't know what's going to happen
and I didn't think the risk was worth
the reward so that's the way I feel
about gambling now about PT and gambling
whatever I don't really believe they're
going to revisit it and I'll call you
you know just seems like you know Pete's
the forgotten guy in a way you know
announced about peds users and etc etc
so you know Pete's case I guess and I'm
not speaking from any special knowledge
I guess this case is then put on the
back she'll tell me about the 1955
Little League state championship
documentary long time coming
Joe what do you got for me well RIT it's
very important to me and I'll tell you
why because in 1955 I was 12 years old
and I lived in California every day I'd
go out I play with you know black kids
white kids Hispanic kids Asian kids so I
played every day with different groups
and then I didn't realize that it was
still that way in 1955 in Florida that
african-americans couldn't play against
the white kids and that was never that's
you know eight years after Jackie
Robinson had been in the major league so
it shocked me at first and then I
watched the story and I started to see
and then I understood it you know there
are a lot of times when the white kids
would forfeit rather than play against
the black kids but I give the Little
League credit for pushing the fact that
they wanted the best team to come out of
it you know out of each state and
therefore you had to play to get there
so two kids would forfeit but the black
kids could not get to the Little League
World Series because you can only take a
couple of four pictures anyway it was
great because these kids twelve year old
kids from Orlando played against you
know the black kids from Pensacola and
they played this game and it's you know
it's that old saying doesn't matter who
went and lost the game but how they
played the game and they played the game
great and they learned a lot of
each other and I say you have to give a
family to both these groups credit
because they let their kids you know be
the first to do this now the great thing
about the movie it's not just about that
game in 1955 it's about 1975 1995 it it
talks about the civil rights struggle
and how we have changed in this country
and then all of those kids that are
around that were kids at the time their
70 year old old mouth they got together
at that same ball field for you reunion
to talk about how their lives have been
affected by that first game and I think
it's great and I was at a screening in
Washington DC last Sunday and I was with
a couple of guys from each team and I
have to tell you it was very emotional
for me because as I said I was 12 years
old and I was able to pursue my dream of
making it to the major leagues kid he's
my kids and Florida were not in not a
place in the south not just Florida they
were not able to pursue their dreams and
I think that's film would it has a
Darren you know talks about it David
Johnson Gary Sheffield and Cal Ripken
jr. so it's a very very well-done film
and it brings out the emotion and the
shows what these kids how that game
changed their race their race
relationships going forward not with
these kids because they didn't see each
other for all those years and they got
together again but I just think it's a
great movie especially in this day and
age when it seems like we're becoming
divided than before and I think the
young people that watch this and the
older people who watch it I think
they'll see that they do have a role and
trying to bring both of the races
together as go forward long time coming
down film and it was way too long my bad
Joe we I'm gonna call you every month
now be careful because I'm gonna do it
for sure you know you're always one of
my favorite advances I really think that
I don't say that too often is but you
were and I really well you are but I
really you know with appreciate prophecy
Joe everyone we'd have to talk on the
air okay you
that's that's done thank you Joe
appreciate it you think that's it that's
Joe Morgan hall Famer
how about that the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience